Hi.
Hi there!
How can I help you?
This basic response simply confirms an agent is available...
...and lets the customer know it's okay to ask their question.
At times, a canned response will not be appropriate...
...especially when online chat users skip the formalities...
...and get straight to the point.
I need to find out your pricing.
Hey there.
Great to hear from you today.
This canned response isn't appropriate.
It's clearly an automated response...
...that doesn't address the customer's specific question,...
...but instead waste their time.
A better response in this situation...
...would be to skip the canned greeting altogether...
...and respond with something like:
Hi, yes I can certainly assist with pricing.
Which product are you looking at?